hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that comes as a suggestion
from quite a few subscribers it's a
ariza versus lex friedman now you guys
are probably thinking oh it's first of
april he's just tricking us again this
game never really happened or who knows
why he's showing this game and yes i
deserve that as i've tricked you pretty
severely uh the the last time but no
this uh this is not such a video uh it'd
be hard to make a video now on the first
of april regardless of what i do since
you guys will be thinking i'm just
tricking you but this is an actual game
so ariza was a guest on the lex friedman
podcast last year in october and they
played a game throughout the entire
podcast and it's a it's quite a lovely
game uh features a very cool opening
features the kings gambit and
well yeah i will just show it because
it's a
really really nice but also if you guys
want to check out the entire podcast i
will put a link to it in the description
below and also there is a video of just
the game that was played at some 15
minutes long so you guys are welcome to
check that out as well as then you can
enjoy commentary by both the reza and
the lex uh themselves uh so that being
said uh let's check out the game and uh
if you're wondering what you could
expect in such a such a podcast well uh
there's really everything in there
there's you know stuff from life and
death there's kung fu there's bruce lee
there's artificial intelligence there is
even uh quite uh quite a a large portion
of the podcast is dedicated to chess so
there's um really a lot to enjoy uh so
you know
if you have some three hours to spare
the links are in the description below
now let's check out what happened in the
actual game so ariza has the white
pieces and he opens with e4 uh sorry
about that
uh lex replies with e5 very very solid
uh and ereza goes for the very
aggressive king's gambit he plays f4 and
lex does not accept the gambit uh he
plays d6 now he's probably thinking okay
rosa plays the king's gambit i'm pretty
sure he knows all the theory and the
king's game but accepted let's surprise
him in the decline the gambit so here
knight to f3 a continuing development
and knight to c6 legs does the same with
bishop to c4 uh white's plan is very
very direct uh he played a four he
played the king's gambit dfi will open
up at some point and he will have
immense pressure over the
f7 pawn it is the weakest pawn in
black's camp the rook will come to f1
probably by castling then we're going to
put more pressure on the f7 pawn
and so on so these are very standard
ideas and lex will of course try
everything to prevent this he develops
the bishop bishop to g4 a natural
developing square as the knight is now
pinned and cannot move and here are just
castles uh and uh now uh lex plays
bishop captures an f3 and here if you
really wanted to make it a a sharp game
you could actually accept the gambit now
and after white grabs the full center
played this g5 idea we got you guys of
course know this as we've covered so
many kings gambling games uh during the
the paul morphy saga and even nowadays
g5 is uh is a well a key move uh in
defending against the king's gambit but
the legs goes for bishop captures an f3
instead uh queen captures on f3 and now
uh you can see that there is a whole lot
of pressure um aimed towards that f7
square now let's plays knight to d4 and
yes lex is neglecting development a
little bit here but it comes
with a certain threat so it's justified
he's attacking the queen and also if the
queen moves to a weird square the knight
captures and c2 will win the rook on a1
uh so reza goes back here if again he
wanted he could give up the rook with a
move like queen to g3 but this would be
maybe two two uh too much uh so queen
back to d1 and only now uh e captures on
f4 uh
probably going for if white now plays d3
with the idea of capturing uh on f4 with
the bishop uh then lex would defend the
pawn with the g5 so reza doesn't allow
him that he plays rook captures on f4
right away and now what do you do the f7
pawn is hanging so obviously we should
defend this with a move like a knight to
f6 uh but alex wants to
get pieces into the game he wants to
develop rapidly and he doesn't care
about king's safety he plays queen to g5
and now uh well now things get very very
interesting as the f7 pawn can just be
captured so bishop captures an f7 with
check we have king to d8 and now pawn to
d3 we have to defend the rook and best
way to defend it is by playing d3 now we
are not just defending the rook but also
we are threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries when the rook moves the
queen will be hanging here so knight to
f6 here lex says uh you don't have any
good discoveries uh whatever you play uh
you know i i can just move the queen
there really isn't a good discovery here
and he is correct in that regard so
knight's the c3 eraser just continues
developing and now uh lex goes uh full
uh attacking mode with the d5
uh here maybe a safer safer approach
would be something like c6 we put a king
on c7 try and bring the rook into the
game somehow but alex plays d5 and again
this is a very very aggressive idea he
wants to bring the bishop to c5 and then
threaten some very nasty discoveries
with
the king still being on g1 and okay
knight captures on d5 uh reza says go
ahead do your thing we have bishop the
c5 now threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries uh and here uh this is a
critical moment and in fact the the
uh black's position is not as
steady as as you might think even though
black has so many pieces out but it's
very very complicated uh so here bishop
to e3 was played ereza was
too too worried about these discoveries
but if uh you know you just wanted to
play this out rook captures on f6 should
win the game for white because now uh as
you as you might have imagined there are
no good discoveries but it's quite a lot
to calculate imagine knight to e2
allowing a double check from the knight
and the bishop the king will have to
move king h1 now knight captures and g3
with check for example and now you have
to see all of this and see that after h
captures on g3 the bishop covers g1 so
the king cannot escape and if you had
one more check it would be checkmate
luckily white is uh defending all of the
three squares so you cannot deliver
checkmate here so if you try and solve
all this out you you will play a move
like rook captures on f6 but ereza plays
the bishop to e3 and now lex is back in
the game he plays knight captures on d5
we have bishop captures on d5 and now
comes a move that uh well uh completely
blows up the game here with knight the
e6 you are sort of back in the game if
you play knight to e6 you are
threatening to pick up the bishop with
check you are attacking the rook here
twice and there really isn't all that
much you can do if you try to win the
black queen with something like rook to
f8 to check the joke would be a new uh
because after black happily accepts the
rook you can't capture the queen the the
bishop cannot move the bishop is
immobilized by the other dark square
bishop on c5 so your best bet after
knight to e6 would be something like uh
d4 blocking the dark square bishop and
now we're going to have something like
knight captures on f4 and after bishop
captures an f4 queen captures d
characters in c5 and this is the
position you would get where black would
be up material uh it would be two rooks
against the bishop and uh a rook however
the black king still needs quite a few
moves to get to safety and uh it would
be a pretty crazy game
so
a move with the knight back is the
correct way to go and you guys know that
uh in most of the times in complicated
positions uh a move with the knight back
is the correct move however here lex
goes forward he plays knight captures on
c2 and it's a similar idea attacking the
rook attacking the bishop twice now if
the bishop moves we're attacking the
rook so it's a complete mess of a
position
and lex is completely winning here
unless ereza finds one move that wins
the game for him so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this move
for ereza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not playing
something weird like capturing the
knight here or capturing uh something
else and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show the move is bishop
captures on c5 this is the only move
that wins the game uh to show you what
happens if you play something uh
something else like queen captures and
c2 well then we just pick up the bishop
on e3 with check and that's it once the
rook moves because you don't want to
give it up for free we're gonna play
rook to fade pile up on this rook and
that's it here white will just resign so
here reza played the absolute best
bishop captures on c5 and now both of
his rooks are on free you can capture
either of them uh but uh
well it's not all that simple if you
capture the the the f4 rook we're just
going to play queen captures on c2 and
now uh here as i would have two bishops
for a rook that's uh yet to be developed
it's not not a pretty sight to look at
so instead after bishop captures on c1
knight captures on a1 is played by lex
and now uh just the bishop back to e3
our rook on f4 is still hanging so
bishop to e3 now we are threatening a
lot of nasty discoveries and there
really is no safe square for lexus queen
to go to wherever you put the queen
we're just gonna play rook to f8 check
and that's pretty much it or rather okay
if you move the queen from here uh we
might um you might be able to save it
but let's say you try queen to e7 still
just rook to f7 there's too many squares
are
now controlled by white after we move
the queen we're gonna play something
like queen captures on a1 also bishop to
g5 check and there's just i mean
it's just game over so instead after
bishop to e3 king that b7 was played by
lex trying to avoid this and well he
also mentioned during the video that uh
putting the king uh
in the center this way could be a little
bit dangerous but now uh of course we
just go for the discovery rook to f7
check king to d8 and now bishop captures
on g5 with check king to e8 wrote the a7
check and he was in this position on
move 19 that alex friedman resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so if you go king d8 then uh well so
many moves win but just queen g4
delivers checkmate on b7 there's no way
to defend this and if you go here then
even a a nice queen to f1 is checkmate
that's all there is
uh so yeah a wonderful uh wonderful game
from very interesting podcast uh like i
said if you guys have uh if you guys
have a lot of time check out the entire
podcast in the description below if you
only have time to check out a game with
their commentary uh it will be the
second link in the description below so
it's like some 15 minutes long and you
can see that um
is very much into chess he uh he if you
watch the podcast he he enjoys talking
about chess quite a lot uh and the both
of them played uh played a really really
nice game alex mentioned that he
uh did not play a lot like in the past
25 years he played maybe maybe five
games but you can see that the
uh the the understanding of the
possession is still there he was very
much into chess
when he was young then he just stopped
playing because he says it was too
addictive uh it took up
too much of his time and if he wanted to
do anything else in life he would have
to
uh you know quit chess so he did so he
could focus on other things uh but you
can see that the the positional side is
still there that he acquired when when
he was very young
uh so yeah a very interesting game hope
you guys enjoyed this i'm not trying to
trick you or anything just because it's
april's fool's day uh so uh you know
hope you really enjoyed this one uh i
would like to thank adam tomczak ferdi
openc smokey doula openc smokey doula
and uh richard mckevin for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
everything else that's happening in the
chess world and checking up your
suggestions uh such as this one uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
yeah i know what you guys are saying how
did lex lose this i mean uh we all know
that he's a robot he should have just
obliterated arizona uh you know it's a
chess game uh but you also guys know
that the first uh sentient life form
that will be able to pass the touring
test will fail it on purpose
so you know
i'm just putting that out there
so yeah i really hope you enjoyed it see
you soon